[Music]
subtract time to eat my food well let's
get let's do it out a closer shot though
get the camera really in there oh it's
got one of those classy new catch of fat
camp wait
it was meant for better than this okay
no this is what you people use but I'm a
host my utensils are carved out of whale
bone yeah that's the recyclable kind oh
this is some one of those help the
planet things uh uh this could be a
channel Oh
sure cool let's see if we can sell this
satellite channel of me just eating my
salad no not let's see that's when you
just go you will sell this yeah the
Conan eats channel except it's never
anything that he really enjoys no a
bunless turkey burger gotta look good so
everyone gets their paycheck
who says that no one is telling you hey
fatty take off the weight all of America
says our ballooning up come on fatso
I read the posts what the pose look at
all
hammering things in the town for the old
Michelin Man trying to keep up with the
youngsters every time I start to eat
something I enjoy I see one of the
cameramen going no no I have a mortgage
I haven't really enjoyed myself in nine
years what was that what was nine years
ago
they reran a Night Stalker that I liked
ah
[Music]